Từ ố đang trải qua một trong những lợt sống nhật gái gác nhất lix sử giỏi bình đồ hiểu.
Tại pháp, lên đầu tiên chính phủ phát cảnh bảo như đồ trên dây giống,
với mấy sảo vùng bảo độc đồ và sống mới tảng cùng bảo độc gác,
khoảng 2,5 đặc phải đón cờ về hàng lống.
Như đồ tại CV của tây bàn nhà đã đạt mất kỳ lục 1,5 đổ xe.
Chính quyết thành phố bác xí lồ nà cũng vừa phải phát đậu một cuộc điều trang huy nhân,
một nữ lọc cầu nằm mới mất tội tử vòng sau khi là độc ngoài trời.
Năng năng vữ giỏi cuộc báo trùm bị tài lia, khi là bù đậu nhá và bán kăng,
kéo theo, vi cơ trải dừng là giọc.
Tại thổ như kì, hơn 5 miệng người đã phải xưa tán dồ trải dừng.
Anh bán đi gì nhận 2 miệng sảo vụ trải trị trong 2 ngày.
Sức vì trải qua ngày nống nhất từ thệ kiểm trai miệch chính.
Chúc bị mỗi năm, sống nhật gấp đi khoảng 1,5 miệng sĩnh mạng tại Châu Âu.
Tổ chức ý tệ dưới về kênh hát ôi cạnh bảo các đường năng nông sẽ ngay càng tương suyên,
giữ giỏi hơn gió khi thàn nhạc kính, đông thời khuyên gắng người dân cũng đủ nước,
hạn chế dân ngoài dơ năng năng năng.
Giữ nhạc gửa mắt mẹ đặc biệt liệu ý bảo vệ người cao tuổi, chả nhỏ,
phụ năng thái và người mắc mạnh mạc tính.
Về các hà đô dự kiến văn hành hình hình hình hình hình hình xấu,
nhằm giúp các chính phủ áp dụng dải phó bảo bảo là mắt bên vững trước ngoài cơ như độc cao, chở thành thường trước.